so how can we start to think about what
it means to exist in a world with
something much much smarter than you
what's what's a good thought experiment
that you've relied on to try to build up
intuition about what happens here
uh I have been struggling for years to
convey this intuition
um the the most success I've had so far
is well imagine that the humans are
running at very high speeds compared to
very slow aliens they're just focusing
on the speed part of it that helps you
get the right kind of intuition forget
the intelligence just because people
understand the power gap of time they
understand that today we have technology
that was not around 1 000 years ago and
that this is a big Power Gap in that it
is bigger than okay so like what does
smart mean what when you ask somebody to
imagine something that's more
intelligent
what does that word mean to them given
that cultural associations that that
person brings to that word
for a lot of people they will think of
like well it sounds like a super chess
player that went to double College
and you know it's it's and because we're
talking about the definitions of words
here that doesn't necessarily mean that
they're wrong it means that the word is
not communicating what I wanted to
communicate
um
so the the thing I want to communicate
is the sort of difference that separates
humans from chimpanzees but that Gap is
so large that you like ask people to be
like well human chimpanzee go another
step along that interval of around the
same length and people's minds just go
blank like how do you even do that
so I can and we can and I can try to
like break it down
and consider what it would mean to send
a schematic for an air conditioner
one thousand years back in time
yeah now I think that there's a sense in
which you could redefine the word magic
to refer to this sort of thing and what
do I mean by this new technical
definition of the word magic I mean that
if you send a schematic for the air
conditioner back in time they can see
exactly what you're telling them to do
but having built this thing they do not
understand how it output cold air
because the air conditioner design uses
the relation between temperature and
pressure
and this is not a law of reality that
they know about they do not know that
when you compress something when you can
when you compress air or like coolant it
gets hotter and you can then like
transfer heat from it to room
temperature air
and then expand it again and now it's
colder and then you can like transfer
heat to that and generate cold air to
block they don't know about any of that
they're looking at a design and they
don't see how the design outputs cold
air it uses aspects of reality that they
have not learned
so magic in the sense is I can tell you
exactly what I'm going to do and even
knowing exactly what I'm going to do you
can't see how I got the results that I
got
this is a really nice example
but is it possible
to linger on this defense is it possible
to have AGI systems that help you make
sense of that schematic weaker AGI
systems do you trust them
fundamental part of building up AGI
is this question
can you trust the output of a system can
you tell if it's lying
I think that's going to be the smarter
the thing gets the more
important that question becomes is it
lying but I guess that's a really hard
question is GPT lying to you even now
gpt4 isn't lying to is it using an
invalid argument is it persuading you
via the kind of process that could
persuade you of false things as well as
true things
because the the basic Paradigm of
machine learning that we are presently
operating under is that you can have the
loss function but only for things you
can evaluate if what you're evaluating
is human thumbs up versus human thumbs
down you learn how to make the human
press thumbs up that doesn't mean that
you're making the human impressive
thumbs up using the kind of rule that
the human thinks is that human wants to
be the case for what they press thumbs
up on
you know maybe you're just learning to
fool the human
that's so fascinating and terrifying the
question of lying
on the present Paradigm what you can
verify is what you get more of
if you can't verify you can't ask the AI
for it
because you can't train it to do things
that you cannot verify now this is not
an absolute law but it's like the basic
dilemma here like maybe you like maybe
you can verify it for simple cases and
then scale it up without retraining it
somehow like by do by like Chain of
Thought by like making the chains of
thought longer or something and like get
more powerful stuff that you can't
verify but which is generalized from the
simpler stuff that did verify and then
the question is did the alignment
generalize along with the capabilities
but like that's the that's the basic
Dilemma on this whole Paradigm of
artificial intelligence
such a difficult problem
it seems like uh
it seems like a problem of trying to
understand the human mind
better than I understands it otherwise
it has magic that is it is you know the
same way that
if you are dealing with something
smarter than you then the same way that
one thousand years earlier they didn't
know about the temperature pressure
relations who knows all kinds of stuff
going on inside your own mind in which
you yourself are unaware
and it can like output something that's
going to end up persuading you of a
thing and or and you could like
see exactly what it did and still not
know why that worked